[Music]
welcome to the starkman's fifth annual
Halloween special the entire month of
October filled with scary horrific
goodness
starting with Gerald's game the new
Stephen King adaptation on Netflix now
not say hey Arnold episode
Gerald's game is directed by Mike
Flanagan the man behind oculus hush and
Ouija origin of evil and it's as I said
a Stephen King adaptation about Jessie
and Gerald an older couple who have lost
their romantic flame and they go to an
old cottage in the middle of nowhere to
have a sexual fantasy and discover
hopefully some romance again he chains
her to the bed with handcuffs and then
he has a heart attack and dies whoopsies
the cleaning people aren't due to show
up in quite some time
they have cut themselves off from their
friends no one's coming to rescue Jessie
they also left the front door open and
there's a rabid dog outside that's
getting hungry now we have a thriller
now if you were to go into a studio and
try to get this movie made and no one
had heard of Stephen King and nobody
knew that it was a book by Stephen King
he'd probably say well it's a captivity
thriller all in one location you could
shoot it for really cheap we'll get some
good actors yeah and the studio would go
yeah that's like the simple way to
describe Gerald's game a captivity
thriller it's so much more than that
though and Stephen King's book was and
Mike Flanagan's adaptation of it
understands that this is a character
study it's about a woman with a past
that's very horrific and this horrible
situation she finds herself in in which
she begins to flashback to all of those
times in her life and it connects to her
present and she realizes why she is the
person she is now and it's sort of like
a self-discovery for her
and it's beautiful this movie is one of
the better Stephen King adaptations out
there
Gerald's game is not one of Kings best
books it's certainly not a bad novel I
mean King cannot write a bad novel even
his worse novels like maybe sell for
instance they're not bad it's just that
it's not one of his better novels but as
an adaptation it gets everything in the
book right there's a few things they've
removed for time purposes obviously and
there's a few minor changes like how the
husband has the heart attack and at what
point in time he has the heart attack
and I like the changes they did a
fantastic job here and Flanagan has once
again proven that he's one of the best
directors working in horror today
because he understands that a real
horror movie is not just about scaring
an audience it's about presenting real
characters in a situation that you can
suddenly relate to no matter how
supernatural it is or how realistic it
is it's about the characters and the
situation's it's not just about scaring
you and Flanagan once again has knocked
it out of the park carla Gugino in this
movie is faced with an insurmountable
task
she has 99.9% of the screen time she is
handcuffed for the majority of the movie
and she has to sell some of the most
serious acting and is almost always in a
constant state of panic now if you've
ever watched actors work on a real set
you know how hard that is to do take
after take and to remain authentic this
is one of the best performances I've
seen so far this year and if there's any
justice with the Academy she'll get
nominated she is fantastic it's her best
work to date I've always been a fan of
her but this is definitely the best I
have ever seen her and not to be
overlooked as Bruce Greenwood who does a
really great job at presenting a strange
and dual character in fact both of them
have to play dual characters because
once she starts to really lose her mind
and become dehydrated she kind of has a
good angel and a bad angel on her
shoulder both of these people speaking
to her and they all have to play
different versions of themselves and
it's rivet
also seamless in this film is the
editing Flanagan has shown a really
great flair for that in the past with
movies like oculus blending the past and
the present to create a cohesive
narrative and he does it here again
extremely well with another really good
performance from Henry Thomas who was
also in ouija origin of evil and very
good in that film he's also creepy as
hell and great here obviously everyone
knows he was great in ET but he was also
really strong in psycho 4 which isn't a
great film by any means and certainly
doesn't recapture the glory of the first
psycho but it's one of the more
underrated performances I've seen from
an actor and Henry Thomas in general I
feel is very underrated once night falls
and a certain individual shows up in
this movie it got under my skin there
are some very unsettling and goosebump
inducing visuals in this movie that had
me on the edge of my seat if you can
tune into this one on Netflix I highly
suggest doing so it's one of the better
King adaptations I've seen it's not an
amazing like life-changing Shawshank
Redemption film but as an adaptation
with the limited things they could do
with the novel and with the characters
they got it all right
the only issue I had with the movie is
basically the same issue I had with a
novel so I won't get into the spoilers
because it involves the ending they
nailed it I mean it's it happened in the
book it's great it's just that it
doesn't always 100% mesh with the feel I
got but I feel like on second viewing it
might improve because once you
understand the entire film from
beginning to end and the goals that
they're going for with certain
characters I feel like on second viewing
it's not gonna be so much of a problem I
highly suggest Gerald's game I'm gonna
give it an A what would you guys say is
the goal with adapting source material
for myself it's either presented
faithfully and accurately or if you're
going to change something improve upon
what was already there some of
Darabont's films did that with Kings
novels
I think Gerald's game does it as well
and please look for
- a ton more reviews and our fifth
annual Halloween special this is a new
release what I'm gonna do throughout
this month is whenever there's a newer
horror movie that's being released like
say jigsaw for instance it'll be filmed
in this awesome Halloween style
background but I'm also going to be
doing a ton of older horror movies with
my wife and with some of my friends
we're all gonna join together and do
hilarious ''tis and we'll do new
releases and old releases it's gonna be
tons of fun guys thank you so much as
always for watching and look forward to
more if you like this you can click
right here and get steppen eyes
[Music]